рішення було хвала для настилки просто
боюся акумуляції суду ванну простота та
швидше валах дискусії стем україни ми
з річки виступають проти штрафних заходів
задні причини diy русі та у сирі та
думаючим брутальність згубних ударі
і скронь в апараті Росії виготовлять овоч
україни ви вирішили легше чон і буде
санкцій через сирію
того ж разу україну геть і точну будуть
повз неї баштою на 2 один контролер
це так легше санкції США цінуватимуть і
про дільничне зняття хтось десантник
такі по суті витрачають своє значення
причина в тому що санкції США миє пак
економічних на злитки для русі ніш
санкцій з
батьку свої черв'я може посилати ти по
зайти те ху європе
хто виступаючи за скошування, а тато
слабкими санкціями
ага та ще через Європу дискусія ще до
санкцій бадану багата на пружині шию за
крим матчі раз позиції франції до
наступна злодіїв змінити а глава держави
на i'm a ver ніші садом президента про
димі людини така вже не настінна
петром і в цьому ж санкції як франсуа
олланд і лондон це над